we've already seen that a vector is
defined by both its magnitude and its
direction and what I want to do in this
video is get some practice calculating
or figuring out the magnitudes of
vectors and I have a vector right over
here vector u it is it is visually
depicted here on our coordinate plane
and I want to figure out its magnitude
and I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can configure it out well
the magnitude of a vector is just the
length of this line you could view it as
the distance between the initial point
and the terminal point right over there
and so one way to think about it you
could view this the magnitude of the
vector let me write this the magnitude
of the vector well you could either
think of it as the distance formula
which really just comes straight out of
the Pythagorean theorem it's going to be
the square root of our change in x
squared change in x squared plus change
in Y squared plus change in Y squared
once again this triangle Greek letter
Delta is just shorthand for change in Y
and this once again comes straight out
of the distance formula which really
comes out of the Pythagorean theorem and
it'll become a little bit more obvious
when I draw the change in Y and I draw
the change in X on this diagram so
what's our change in Y well we're
starting at our initial point we're
starting at Y is equal to 9 and we are
to get to the Y value of our terminal
point we're going down to Y is equal to
2 so we have a change in Y our change in
Y is equal to going from 9 to 2 our
change in Y is negative 7 similarly our
change in X we're going from X is equal
to 2 to X is equal to 5 so our change in
the horizontal direction is plus 3 so
our change in X or we could even think
of this as the horizontal component of
the vector this is equal to positive 3
and as we've just seen we have drawn a
right triangle and so we could use a
Pythagorean theorem to figure out to
figure out the length of the hypotenuse
and you might say wait wait a length of
a side of a triangle can't have an egg
value and that's why these Squared's are
valuable because it doesn't matter if
you're taking a negative seven squared
or a positive seven square you're going
to get a positive value here and if you
really just view this as a triangle all
you care about is the length of this
side right over here or that's the
magnitude of this side or the absolute
value of it which is just going to be
positive seven and so we can say this is
going to be equal to the magnitude of
our vector is going to be equal to so 3
squared is 9 9 and then negative 7
squared is positive 49 so plus 49 well
once again you could view this as our
change in Y squared which is negative 7
squared or you could say well I'll just
look the absolute value the length of
the side we don't want to think of a
side as having a negative value the
negative really just says hey we're
going from the top to the bottom it
gives us our direction but if we just
say the length of it it's 7 when you
there if you just use the Pythagorean
theorem 7 squared would also be 49 and
so either way you get the magnitude of
our vector is equal to the square root
of 9 plus 49 is going to be 50 57 now I
don't think I can simplify this radical
too much that's that's it so the
magnitude of this of this vector is the
square root of 57